[Music]
good morning
[Applause]
that's a man version of a bbo what's
that yo guys like big butts so girls get
big butts girls likes tall guys this guy
get tall that's a man BBL
it's actually what he's doing there
super painful super long
but it's actually less live threatening
than the BBL so I'm not saying go ahead
and do it I'm all live for you that's
true
BBL is very dangerous compared to this
yeah because you're just breaking bones
there's no arteries real close anyways
uh have you researched this surgery no
but I know where the location of the put
but the thing is they break bones they
break bones and they put this is
I'm not gonna go say go ahead and go do
it
go ahead and go do it it's like I'm not
gonna do that I'm not I'm not gonna be
the one I'm not gonna be the one but am
I surprised by it no of course it was
about to happen like BBL is extremely
dangerous but anyways I digress
it's very invasive to just do that to
your body this is wild I'm reading some
of this stuff and they're like if you
don't have a team with you the whole way
yeah if that thing just comes apart it
can undo the whole yeah you have to have
a team with you because basically what
they do is this
when you break your bones
okay when you break your bones and they
put it together your bone actually
secretes a substance that's going to jam
it together and you're going to be able
to redo itself right so what they do for
you to uh to grow is that they basically
break your bone
and put a gap
and bring it again and bring it to the
Gap and another Gap and another Gap so
the bone always secretes that the
substance until there's that gap between
them right which is going to be
solidified basically you're breaking
something and you weld it with a big ass
weld that's what they're doing with your
bones okay so if you don't have a team
with you with a brace it's not a line
you could have problems with your with
yeah you can't even run again huh can't
even run no because you you know how yo
whenever you weld something they need
people try not to weld things like the
welders and stuff like that metal
workers they try not to weld things they
could bend the metal and have something
to solidify it that's good but like
break a straight line and weld it
together that's never a good spot it's a
weak joint it's a weak place that's a
point of failure there if it's gonna be
it's gonna fail there because it's not
one long one it's not one single thing
you just put two things together all
right it's never going to be as strong
never gonna be as strong so it's exactly
like welding so yeah running put a lot
of stress on your body running fast the
faster you go the faster the bigger the
The more stress it does to your body you
know how I know I used to run tracks
okay that's what I used to do for a
living I wanted to go to the Olympics
but you know life decided another way
and it's a lot of stress on your body
and your joint and your bone most people
that I know that weren't that run tracks
they have knee problems
most people that run tracks have
problems with their hips and
it's a lot of stress so when you're
going to break the bone and put it back
together without it
it's just it's normal yeah it's gonna
it's gonna be something different it's
gonna be something more fragile it's
like whenever you see those those MMA
things where they got kicks yeah and the
thing snaps off
first and foremost if you think that
person is going to be back operational
with kale with kale kale just eating
kale and and and and and
natural stuff no with the money in line
they they use other things okay just if
you don't understand what I'm talking
about watch Captain America anyways
all natural oh all patriotism actually
it's all natural
in the period that they train let's go
uh out of that whatever happened happens
but that's besides the point okay
whenever you it's never gonna be the
same
your your foot your leg is never gonna
be the same
whatever is done by professional or by
by accident you snap it off it goes back
together your leg is not the same you
gotta translate now
that's crazy I did not know this kind of
surgery really existed and it's been
it's been there for a long time yeah but
apparently like most doctors don't want
to do it for cosmetic reasons
of course because it's super dangerous
it's long it's not super dangerous it's
long it's what's dangerous is not the
fact that the procedure itself it's your
afterlife yeah if after it's your life
after the procedure itself it's not that
this is dangerous I mean the recovery
you mean the recovery is is my nerve
damage it might not the recovery is wet
so it's not as Diamond like it's not as
dangerous in terms of life threatening
and I like lack the more qualifications
not necessarily be I think like BBS will
probably have less complications yes
I wouldn't say so of course for just
cosmetic reasons it's a lot to go
through for just a couple of inches it's
not like you're gonna grow a foot
I mean growing five inches a lot yes it
is I'm not gonna lie like if it was two
inches I'm like you guys are [__]
five inches is a lot I can't even be mad
at them completely damn I'm gonna go
from five to ten to but the worst part
like the dude is a good looking guy
doesn't matter
from five five to six foot
welcome to the master race
your application is still under
consideration
because we need to see if your leg is
gonna stick but welcome to the master
race I mean we don't know if the leg
almost thick we don't even know if he
can the stick can run
oh it looks weird to look at let's keep
watching
I don't know I don't know that's not
even only that it's when he gets hope
when he gets old I wasn't going to me
you know I mean you're gonna be a tall
ass [__] that can't walk
congratulations I'm gonna be honest with
you
is it shocking kind of kind of
because it's just like
I knew this future was coming I just
didn't know what it would look like
that's all I'm not shocked by what's
happening I'm just shocked at seeing you
does that make sense
it's like you might know a punch is
coming but once that thing's swinging
for your face your eyes are still going
to open up like oh [__] that's what this
is like for me
but this is the world that we created I
mean once we started with the Botox and
all this other stuff and then the
titties then the boobs and the butt ABS
I mean this is just an extension of what
we've already normalized and this is
just a
this is just the beginning of this [__]
you're gonna get wider shoulders I'm
telling you man that cyberpunk Future
Sounds [__] lit I'm not gonna lie if
I get a chance to get Bionic legs I'm
doing that I'm not gonna get what this
guy got because I that's how I feel
when a surgery comes out I'm like bro I
ain't touching that [__] for the first
10 15 years if you want to give me a
cybernetic I'm down but I need to see 3
000 [__] have it for a few
years before I even considers and then
I'm ready for that robot eye it's like
the first phone
never get the first chance let them
clear out the bugs nothing tells me you
don't care about yourself like just
being one of the first people in life
for new surgery
like I get it you insecure but you just
don't give a [__] [__]
Instagram now they need to happen now
yeah wait till you [__] all like ah
Stephen Hawking right and then you're
gonna be really insecure I'm just saying
I'm not gonna be the number one person
let other people
wild stuff man in the last 20 years the
way the world has changed is so crazy
like I can honestly say up until I was
like yeah until 2000 I really felt like
to think of the children the internet
got introduced in the late late 90s I
remember when the internet started
getting popular late nights you
definitely felt like there was a change
but the internet was such an infant
stage everything now you got AI going
crazy you got people lengtheningly
bodies through breaking their bones you
got women taking fat out of their
stomach and injecting their ass which
gives them abs and a booty that don't
make no sense they can't sit on it for a
while but that's okay because now
everybody want to grab their booty then
you got girls injecting things into it
and then putting silicone plastic and
then coming to find out it's cancerous
so they just replace it with another
it's crazy
[__] is crazy [__] is crazy
like bro imagine in 10 years
you could probably permanently change
your eyes I'm good
what am I talking about we can do that
right now yeah they put something over
they cut it open and put something on
top of it yeah shit's crazy bro it is
life is mad as crazy how things have
changed but anyways cut it open I just
wanted to play this for y'all just to
see what you guys think what do you guys
feel this says about the future are you
guys excited or not do you guys want a
cyberpunk future what I'm not excited
you don't want to do cyberpunk no I'm
good but it's not like I'm gonna have a
choice okay hypothetical
what if they give you like a pissing
action dick oh what like it amplifies
the pleasure for you and your girl
no I'm good it's like titanium like
floppy dude I'm good I'm good it is but
the more you go like activate it goes
like piston action like this pause
okay
what did you
do that it's an action this [__]
even hey yo hey yo
let us know what you guys think of each
other
[Music]